I am asking specifically calling for the
genocide of Jews does that constitute
bullying or harassment representative
she's from New York Republican Elise
stefanic asked MIT president Sally
cornbluth and Pen president Liz McGill
if it's okay to call for the genocide of
the Jews I might recommend that before
we play this clip that you adjust
yourself and make sure you're sitting in
your seat securely because you might
actually fall out of your chair
Dr corn BL does m at MIT does calling
for the genocide of Jews violate mit's
code of conduct or rules regarding
bullying and harassment yes or no if
targeted at individuals not making
public
statements yes or no calling for the
genocide of Jews does not constitute
bullying and harassment I have not heard
calling for the genocide for Jews on our
campus but you've heard chance for
in I've heard chance which can be
anti-semitic depending on the context
when calling for the elimination of the
Jewish people so those would not be
according to the mit's code of conduct
or
rules that would be um investigated of
as harassment if pervasive and severe
Miss Migel at pen does calling for the
genocide of Jews violate Penn's rules or
code of conduct yes or
no if the speech turns into conduct it
can be harassment yes I am asking
specifically calling for the genocide of
Jews does that constitute bullying or
harassment if it is directed and severe
or pervasive it is harassment so the
answer is yes it is a context dependent
decision congresswoman it's a context
dependent decision that's your testimony
today calling for the genocide of Jews
is depending upon the context that is
not bullying or harassment this is the
easiest question to answer yes Miss
Mill so is your testimony that you will
not answer yes if it uh is if the speech
becomes if the speech becomes conduct it
can be harassment yes conduct meaning
committing the act of
genocide the speech is not harassment
this is unacceptable Miss Migel I'm
going to give you one more opportunity
for the world to see your answer does
calling for the genocide of Jews violate
Penn's code of conduct when it comes to
bullying and harassment yes or
no it can be harassment the answer is
yes you know I've watched this five
times this morning and I'm still almost
speechless first off that lady there at
the end um the smile she's smiling the
whole time like I think the devil is in
her like she has been possessed by the
devil I don't know that I exactly mean
that literally but I kind of do in in a
real spiritual sense these people have
become rotten from the inside uh there
was so much obfuscation there first off
I want to give real credit can we can we
try to get uh Alise stefanic on the show
I think we we almost had her on about a
year ago I want to try to get her on the
show she did an absolutely great job
very cleanly clearly laying out come on
now like come on I'm giving you a chance
here the whole world's watching and the
Devil Woman with that smile uh you have
to also remember before I get into some
of the specifics these schools for the
last five seven years we have been told
that these kids should be issued
microaggressions and Trigger warnings
and they should be told if they're going
to be discussing something that might
upset them and everything else and
they're you know the generation
Snowflake and we shouldn't upset them
and it's their truth and all of these
things suddenly when it comes to calling
for extermination of one particular
minority well as one of them said only
when speech turns into conduct and as
Alise stepanic said yes that would be
the genocide
so you can defend free speech and also
say uh you know if you keep calling for
genocide we're going to kill all the
Jews or all that that actually is
harassment a school is allowed to have a
harassment policy right that that they
can have their own uh rules and
regulations around and Dr Gay at Harvard
does calling for the genocide of Jews
violate Harvard's rules of bullying and
harassment yes or no it can be depending
on the context what's the context
targeted as an individual targeted as at
an individual it's targeted at Jewish
students Jewish individuals do you
understand your testimony is
dehumanizing them do you understand that
dehumanization is part of
anti-Semitism I will ask you one more
time does calling for the genocide of
Jews violate Harvard's rules of bullying
and harassment yes or
no anti-semitic rhetoric when it
anti-semitic rhetoric anti-semitic
rhetoric when it crosses into conduct
that amounts to bullying harassment
intimidation that is actionable conduct
and we do take action so the answer is
yes that calling for the genocide of
Jews violates Harvard code of conduct
[Music]
correct again it depends on the context
it does not depend on the context the
answer is yes and this is why you should
resign these are unacceptable answers
across the
board